hi how are you Spooky's House of
jump-scares
oh here we go
hi spooky ah so stayed hello well it's
quite lovely
yes thousand no probably not
you don't know what too freaky really
but you can't just leave god damnit
thousand rooms alright
telling six seven again probably not
okay that was room one really all right
that's easy this game is easy hello
alright um roommate nothing is happening
I know where the jump scares me every
time I play horror game only 985 rooms
left whoa get excited Jesus Christ
there's a lot of rooms I do have a
health bar I don't know what's up with
that I don't know what the [ __ ] oh my
god is spider this game is just like
humiliation your humiliation oh my god
why is this game scary why ah so so many
goddamn the tension is going up in my
butt literally Edgar could you stop
doing that
now I keep getting this feeling like I
am being washed or something this is not
romantic at all
Thanks
[Music]
all right you know what
just cus you're so goddamn adorable I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna yell at you you
know what I'm gonna there you go have a
kiss you're so cute gara me again and I
will [ __ ] stab you to death though
you're not just cut your sock ha what
hang in motivational kitty what what are
we going down we are going down please
don't kill me that's the funny you held
a bet that what did I say mister ghosty
don't give me that look now goddamn it
you're cute just keep going it's just a
cute [ __ ] horror game I played Silent
Hill oh god pumpkin stop stop why you do
this pumpkin tink not quite quenching my
thirst taste is terrible stains are
terrible I don't think drinking it was a
very romantic idea why would you
I don't okay we're gonna make it to room
thousand nah tink listing Oh God
Luigi rod oh god the ink it's slowing me
down
[ __ ] okay God okay God sixty-six yeah
I'm being chaste breath what the [ __ ]
happened this game was so cute no Sokka
room sixty-nine sorry I'm sorry
Gary s game I have ever played oh my god
oh my god just go
stop drinking ink you stupid idiot go go
go go go go go are you with me proud
we're almost at 100 how did this game go
from the cutest [ __ ] thing ever
to the meanest little [ __ ] machine it's
kind of like most girls I date except my
say of course sorry I'm sorry oh god oh
god oh my god this game is so
humiliating to play it while you record
cuz this is you play down your own no
one gets to see you get scared from the
dumbest [ __ ] ever 100 high five buzz oh
my god we can save here okay that's cool
alright we have we did one tenth of the
game one [ __ ] tenth what's the rest
of this game got to offer I don't want
to know I genuinely don't only 895 more
rooms to get out 94 oh yeah let's
I'm excited what the hell happened here
I don't like how it gets creepy
air-locked what the [ __ ] you can't be
locked
what now what is this Oh No Oh what the
[ __ ] Raptor
no bad Raptor yeah gosh one escaped one
escaped hello
oh [ __ ] oh god I hear I hear I hear
something fine
I [ __ ] hear it's a spider it's a
[ __ ] spider I am NOT gonna be chased
for 80 [ __ ] rooms alright math how
does it work Oh God ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] a one more head and I'm dead
are you kidding me oh this is not even
[ __ ] funny this better not be a dead
end it's better not be a dead end it's
better not be if Jess aah oh my god
oh my god yes it's basically a corridor
simulator but a very good one and that
beam am aiming im so spooked
I'm so spooked I am spooked I am spooky
what where do I get the flashlight no no
it's like one of these Japanese horror
games I don't want to be inside of one
of these games I'd really don't
ah what is that sound don't want to know
my god scam is system giant spitting no
God not this [ __ ] again where is he
Oh oh my god she's after me oh god I
gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta go gotta
get that boom shut up ahh oh my god this
game is worse than [ __ ] five nights
at Freddy's I'm so focus I'm running
I can almost 200 a [ __ ] brain and
blood y ou don't have time to find out
hey gotta go you don't even look like
you're struggling alright - shut up I'm
struggling I'm a struggler and a thug
ler my mom said it
[Music]
surprisingly that one didn't scare me
what
what's the smack Oh Oh got it uh I think
I have ectoplasm in my in my fast stuff
oh god no I saw something I saw
something can this [ __ ] thing get off
me God stop [ __ ] it slows me down
it's so [ __ ] annoying oh thank god
don't like ischemic vi really mean hey
what this [ __ ] yes I'm very proud Thanks
what is it what do you think what is it
nice painting what is it all right this
better be good
oh [ __ ] you
you're mean alright they're really
really [ __ ] me
I'm in hell event it up what the [ __ ] is
this I know it crashed no mind me I'm
just gonna redo 30 rooms okay here's the
computer that made me crash what the
[ __ ] is this
eat Doss a cardboard kind of figure that
Springs out prude not very efficient
against healthy seconds what their [ __ ]
it stays the [ __ ] is this Valda come on
all right you just walk there oh yeah
that's a puss though I remember okay I
have a feeling I should not be going in
here let's go oh my god what is this
Valley the cells not creepypasta or some
[ __ ] I don't don't know one don't worry
about me brah I'm just gonna go yeah he
stabbed my anus you piece of [ __ ] no let
me regenerate my heart listen I have a
lot of rooms to go three or I don't have
time to play around in [ __ ] I'm just
gonna keep looking at him oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god all
right all right
that's it that's it no no
I'm playing this game for the
alright alright then that's great
does that mean I can't continue if I
really don't know how to get rid of him
oh you asked licking shit-faced don't
even know if this is [ __ ] necessary
but Jesus Christ I don't want him to
kill me again that was [ __ ] terrible
I hate this part
all hail kitty I don't know is that what
they do in The Hunger Games all right
cool am i cool oh oh how nice
[Music]
threshold of consciousness thank you I
guess are you lost
[Music]
son of a [ __ ] I didn't expect turmoil
oh all right then
wrong room son of a [ __ ]
all right yes I am swimming around and
evide high okay I was not ready to see
that
[Music]
damnit I died what happened you were so
cute what is all days I'm still in 410 I
don't [ __ ] understand I am missing
something here no no no [ __ ] is chasing
me chasing me jessamy she's chasing me
[ __ ] is chasing me [ __ ] chase i'm a
[ __ ] chasing me one more Oh spooky
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
thank you yep still alive thanks I don't
like her game save whatever happens it
will happen in the next episode Russ if
you enjoyed this episode please leave a
like it would help me out a lot this is
quite a challenge not gonna lie I'm kind
of [ __ ] exhausted so I'd appreciate
it let me know if you want in of course
you do
you dirty [ __ ] sorry I'm thank you for
watching I always appreciate it this is
how Satan was born I don't know why
Taylor Swift keeps popping up in my head
there's something that needs to be done
oh my god I've created Satan how did
this happen